heuteam h mal über Leid wo sich selber
behauptet ich lüge eigentlich lügt oder
Zeit Lösig zu dem schönen ratel geht's
ganz am Schluss vom
[Musik]
Video jetzt wfen was das überhaupt ist
Wort der Friedrich Nietsche hat gemeint
wahrheiten sind Illusionen von denen man
vergessen hat dass sie welche sind
stimmt das oder ist Wort meh als das
sprich gibt Objektiv Wort Begriff
immer wichtiger wird in Z V Fake News
und Deep Fakes erinnert der PAP dasil wi
Daun Jae aber wieder in Z V
propagandawort ukrainrieg V
verschwörungsthorie und von der
sogenannte gefühlte wor wo jed und jeder
mit wir m dring klar was das überhaupt
ist wor um zu Verst was wor ist hilft
sie abzugrenze V Wahrhaftigkeit
Wahrhaftigkeit heißt ich sage was ich
wirklich denke ich bin also ehrlich und
ich lüge nicht aber Achtung nicht J die
whaf Aussag ist per se auch war Aussag
ich verworhte was falsch ist z.B D Erde
schieben ist wie die sogenannte Flat e
wenn ich das tatsächlich
Glaube kann ich auch whaftig
dass schieben ist das selber ist aber
falsch und BBT falsch egal ich oder
nicht wenn ich glaube dass schieben ist
den ist W für mich es ist ein Mini wor
das ist aber sehr unkau formuliert wenn
das einach so W da könnte ich mich gar
nicht TÜ alles was ich für W halte wä
den ja war nämlich für mich es gibt kein
Wort ich sondern n oder Mini wor und
alle hat recht das war absurd halte fest
wor ist anders als whaftigkeit komen wir
zu der erste bekannte Theorie von oder
Wort der Korrespondenztheorie die
behauptet wor ist ein Satz oder ein
Gedanke genau denn wenn er mit der
Wirklichkeit über i stimmt wenn es also
ein Korrespondenz geht zwischen Aussag
auf der ein Site und Wirklichkeit auf
der andere Seite oder anders gesag Satz
ist genau den wor wenn er der Tatsache
entspricht wenn was er also behauptet
tatsächlich der Fall ist St das schonim
aristotelesilosoph oder den aufk beim
Imanuel
kan die Theorie wirft wenn man länger
drüber noch denkt viele Fragen auf
erstens was ist genau ein Tatsach gibt
z.B auch moralische Tatsache oder
negative Tatsache z.B dass es kein
eihörner geht ist das ein Tatsach und
was heißt genau Korrespondenz wie Sproch
überhaupt das Abbild sie von der
Realität und ganz allgemein was nützt
diesen Idee VW wenn man nie sicher sie
die wirkliche Realität gefunden h ob es
also wirklich so eine Korrespondenz geht
all die Frage h Z witer worstheorie
geführt nämlich zu der pragmatische
worstheorie die Theorie SEAG dass ein
überzügig genau denn war ist wenn sie im
Le oder im denk wiederbringt wenn sie
hilft wenn Sie also nützlich ist das Z
wieder geht z.B mit der überzugig sind
wir bisher ganz gut gefahren also dürfen
wir sie wor nennen wor überzügige sind
kein Spiegel von der Realität sondern
meh wie ein guute Kompass oder wie kte
wo zum Ziel bringt das Modell wo sich
bewt mE nicht das zumindest mein der
William James der hauptvertretter von
der pragmatische wor Theorie ob Welt
wirklich so ist wie bestimmte Theorie
behauptet das wer man nie könfen das
einzige Kriterium ist ein Theorie
funktioniert oder nicht sie bringt zum
Ziel oder nicht und gut nicht ob sie
funktioniert oder nicht das wsen wir im
Unterschied zu der Frage Theorie
tatsächlich mit objektive Welt über
stimmt wie sie ganz unabhängig von
Menschen ist wenn aber Kön danke h die
Theorie i blinde Flack will was heißt
schon funktionierere viele l hilft zump
der Glaube schutzangel oder an das
Schicksal heißt das jetzt aber we den
gibt schutzangel oder das Schicksal und
was ist wenn sich zwei Theorie wiedprech
aber beide auf ih Art irgendwie nützlich
sind sind den beide war undt
widersprüchlich Problem wi wororie
nämlich die sogenannte kohärenzthorie
die behauptet ist überzügig denn wenn
viele andere überzügige sie stützet wenn
Meinig also das ganzes Netz V
überzügiger wo man schon h und
nichterspruch St zu den das Problem ist
schworie und rassistische Ideologie sind
es Netz vüberzügige wo sich gtig stützet
aber wor sind nicht zu der letzte
Theorie der Konsens Theorie die Theorie
behauptet wor istag den W möglich viel l
glaub wenn es also ein großer Konsens
geht genauit nicht irgendwche sondern
Expertin und Experte sprich die die
Theorie got zurück auf der Charles
Sanders per aber auf der Jürgen haberma
ein von derich Philosoph V gwart blöde
der theor Expertin und Experte Kön
falsch wie alle W oder sie K sich
wiedersprechen zum Fazit alle woror sind
irgendwie unbefriedigend aus dem Grund h
Philosoph gefordert wir s ganz
verabscheden vom Begriff Wort und n
davor redet dass ein Meinig oder Theorie
gerechtfertigt ist gut Gründ für Sie
wahrscheinlich ist oder dass sie sich
bewährt dass sie also noch nicht wieder
leid ist viele Philosophin und
philosophe mein aber um der Griff von
der Objektive wor wir unmöglich der
Macht nmlich möglich dass wir mit dies
Aussage jederzeit düche und das ist
wichtig gab's ja weder sinnvoll
strickspräch noch ein wissenschaftlicher
Fortschritt so viel also z wor und jetzt
noch zum K rel vom Anfang der Satz ich
lüge ist ein klassischer Fall von ein
sogenannte Antinomie AK ich sagt Wort
den stimmt was ich behaupte ich behaupte
aber dass ich lüge also lüge ich wenn
ich aber tatsächlich Lüge dann geht
Gegenteil von dem was ich behaupte also
sag ich Wort egal was ich folgt immer
das Gegenteil dusus also g egal ob Wort
oder lüg es blibt knifflig ja was
versteht ihr unter Wort gibt's ein
Objektiv wor oder soll wir ganz zufüre
von wor diskutier mit schrib die
Kommentar aber no wor Sache bitte und
dann findet ein sternstund zum Thema
wüssse und kurzes erklarstück zum Thema
Skepsis